die niedersächsische gemeinde langeoog
a2 neue fähranleger gebaut ein auf der
insel und ein lamm festland stolze 5,4
millionen euro kosten die brücken aber
an den schönen neuen anlegern kann kein
schiff festmachen der grund die beiden
rampen sind 40 zentimeter zu lang
geraten deshalb müssen die passagiere am
alten anleger umständlich ein und
aussteigen beklagt das ist ein
wunderbarer schildbürgerstreich wieder
das hat so lange gedauert stört auch
jetzt die reisenden amateurhaft total
amateurhaft bin ich ganz ehrlich das
wäre mir als laie glaube ich noch nicht
mal passiert wenn ich was aus meiner
sicht ist ja eindeutig eine fehlplanung
seit 2015 plant die gemeinde ihre alten
fähranleger durch neue zu ersetzen als
2020 alles fertig ist gibt es eine böse
überraschung die elektro who brücken
über die das gepäck transportiert werden
soll sind 40 cm zu lang
dadurch passen aber auch die brücken für
die passagiere nicht ans schiff an die
neuen fähranlegern können fähren nicht
anlegen
reisende müssen über diese notlösung an
bord mit einem frachter wird ihr gepäck
hinterhergefahren
allein dafür zahlt die gemeinde bis zu
200.000 euro pro monat extra das ist ein
transportweg der extrem wichtig ist und
der den dann so zu behindern das finde
ich eigentlich das geht ja ich denke ich
müssen vor allem die mitarbeiter der
schifffahrt das ausbaden weil die
natürlich den frust sowohl der insulaner
als auch der an- und abreisenden gäste
abbekommen
im rathaus von langeoog macht man
keinerlei anstalten das baudebakel
kleinzureden
wir können immer nur sagen wie leid uns
das tut aber wir können es nicht ändern
ist es muss ja wirklich ordentlich auch
repariert in anzug strichen werden es
ist ja eine brücke die 30 40 jahre unter
einer extremen belastung steht seit
einem jahr stehen die vier anlieger
nutzlos in der gegend herum an der
nordsee haben sie wenig hoffnung dass
sich das schnell ändern wird
das ist einfach traurig dass leute sich
dahin setzung was planen und das dann
nicht der realität entspricht und wieder
haufenweise geld in
angesetzt wird im prinzip muss derjenige
es viel geplant hatten der muss dafür
aufkommen
ein neues planungsbüro soll sich jetzt
um den umbau kümmern wann die
fähranleger endlich genutzt werden
können kann derzeit niemand verlässlich
sagen und wir haben ende auf den
zusätzlichen kosten sitzenbleiben wird
muss auch noch geklärt werden